Tom what's amazing about the evolution
of the conversations that we have around
this topic is how quickly they change
and how quickly it evolves in the
afterword for the novel which was
published in 2000 the author David Heber
Schaaf talks about sex change surgery
and very recently we talked about gender
reassignment surgery and now I think
you're talking about gender confirmation
and what's that always kind of part of
your thanking that Lilly was there from
the very beginning this has been a
seven-year passion project I fell in
love with the script late 2008 when I
was in early talks about directing The
King's Speech and lucinda script just
blew my mind I was so moved by the love
story at the center this sort of story
of unconditional love but but on this
film that makes me a newbie a relative
newcomer because my wonderful producers
Gail matrix nan harrison Gail has been
fighting to make this film for 15 years
you know there's been a rapid and
extraordinary evolution and I've
experiences it as a director because
I've gone from you know my early
conversations you know Gail Ann and I
had you know it was it was it considered
a difficult film to get made a hard film
to finance a hard film to cast I wanted
to cast this kid called Eddie Redmayne
people people thought that was a crazy
idea and and and now you know people
tell me it's a timely movie even a
zeitgeist movie and and and it it shows
there's been this extraordinary change
in in in the perception of trans
narratives and it's like there's been a
tipping point moment for trans
narratives this year with with
extraordinary television like
transparent orange is the new black both
Caitlyn Jenner's generosity in sharing
her story to the world as she has but
but but but as John beautifully put it
with the evolution of David talking
about a sex change to gender
reassignment gender confirmation surgery
this is also allowed the beginnings of a
real compassionate understanding of
what's at the center of this and what
the center at the center of this story
is is a woman who was always there
always waiting and I came to the story
through the novel I hadn't heard about
the story before and I was amazed that
it existed and so I think it's always
reading the novel I was I was kind of
researching as I went along and so
the historical version of events and the
fictionalized version of events were
kind of concurrent in my head and I
suppose the first thing I did was strip
out as much as the fiction as I could
and I think you know a great deal of
that's gone on it and the story is now
much closer to to the events as they
happened there wasn't a huge amount of
very good data about iron girder for all
sorts of reasons I mean partly to do
with the way women's and queer history
tends not to survive but also because of
what happened in Europe in the 30s
shortly after those operations so Lili
Albers medical records for example were
held in the Women's Hospital in Dresden
which did not exist by the end of the
war it had been born into obliteration
so gradually we had great researchers to
help us the producers had terrific
researcher who helped me enormously with
finding academic research and and
research that was in Danish and so on
but I think my feeling was always - I
always wanted to take the story much
closer to the Koppel I wanted it to be a
very intimate under the skin account of
that marriage I didn't really know how
else you could go the journey with them
other than to really be very immersed
and and inside that marriage so that you
know at the beginning of it I not
presented as absolutely persuasively
male and by the end of it you look back
and realized that that was always Lily
and I think the only way you could
really make that arc was to really be
under the skin of it so my process was
really about getting rid of as much
leaving out as much as I could in a
sense obviously this is a historical
story about a true life person but
you're also in conversation with people
who are alive today who are living as
transgendered people um I suppose it was
really everything from the UI I never
quite know how to start preparing to
play a character I always would hope in
some ways that a character dictates that
and certainly with this film as you
cinder said it was about immersing
yourself in as much of the history as
you could but then the really important
for me was the emotional side and was
meeting trans women living now and their
partners and hearing their stories and
across the board every woman that I met
almost bar none would start the
conversation by going there is no
question I'm not willing to answer and
the need to educate me was overwhelming
and of course as these people opened
their hearts and really shared their
experience one sense of responsibility
grew but it was important also to to
meet women of different generations and
and then really to try and take that
information along with the history and
place that in a context of the 1920s
when Lily didn't have the vocabulary she
didn't have the community she didn't
have them really when doctors were
pathologizing what she had there was
there was no other context so I that's
how I went about it so much of this
story is obvious about I nourish
transformation or revelation to Lily but
Gerda go through her own transformation
in terms of how she sees her partner and
how she sees herself in relation to her
partner that's a good thing that you
point about it out because that was one
of the things when I met like Eddie even
more for preparing for Gerda people who
were friends or family members or loved
ones to people transitioning was the
fact that they wanted to point out that
they also went on this big change
themselves and that what I immediately
thought you know was an amazing and a
unique love story but but I could relate
to the fact of a couple going on a big
journey in a big change and how those
two people try to find their new place
in a new relation to each other but I
think when I spoke to Tom quite early on
when in preparation for this role it was
about finding that strength and courage
and core of Gerda that I think we're all
quite well I'm very impressed by by the
kind of immense belief and love and
unconditional love for somebody
I love that I think that was also
brilliant thing that Luke sinner put in
the script how good is an artist a
painter not as successful as lily as I
know the beginning but she's trying to
find her voice and I love that she threw
like any artist when you finally find
your truth is also when you start have
become successful normally in your art
and people actually acknowledge it and
her subconscious in the beginning of the
film actually releases her inner idea of
being able to see the truth in her
partner and that that actually comes out
in the beginning from her subconscious
through her art and I thought that was a
very beautiful thing one of the
important things we wanted to show all
the time is like Lily was always there
trap in a in a sort of like body that
didn't was hers and we found you know a
way to show it like almost dressing her
at the beginning in this or this
masculine so like are more like really
Edwardian with a you know really really
sort of constrain and then you know
through the whole movie we start like
trying to see her evolving out of this
prison let's say and working with
fabrics a movement with color with you
know I mean we were also very fortunate
because we were working in the 20s and
the twenties was a very very moment a
liberating moment for fashion in women
and we found that very very soft very
very big advantage to us and it was a
difficult task I think but you know when
you are so lucky that you have actors
like these two then the whole thing
becomes much much easier I think and
yeah I mean you know it was very very
challenging and and I think it has been
an amazing journey because the
implications of the project and how
important is to show you know this this
this character becoming into life and
being believable and helping her to
become free you know that was that was
one of the main aim is I think Danny I
want to ask you a little bit about
how you shot Einar compared to lily and
I think subtly you can notice there's a
little bit of difference in where the
camera is position why was that
important and what do you think that
reinforces even subconsciously in the
way the audience looks at those two
characters yeah I think one of the
things I think we start when we did a
little bit of testing before we started
the shoot itself and Tom was quite keen
on playing around with the height of the
camera and then kind of do some shooting
stuff and then kind of looking at the
rushes and one of the things we kind of
hit on was Tom really liked the camera
being slightly above Eddie looking down
for when Eddie was in Lily and I think
what what the the change in perspective
kind of adds as erm just executives or
accentuates Eddie's Soloff first of all
as bone structure becomes more apparent
and and there's felt like there is more
beauty from being slightly up looking
down as opposed to on the same level or
down looking up so that kind of plays
through the film which I think works
quite long yeah we took great reference
from girders paintings and especially as
Lily almost became Gerda's Muse her are
exploded into this great kind of
wonderful set of curves and as they both
point out femininity was the key here
this colours were soft and pink and lime
sexy and capacious and that led us
directly to the are nouveau interiors
and they were contemporary to them at
that time so you know two characters so
into art so into their painting
photography it was an easy it was a way
of reflecting the truth that was painted
by Gerda on canvas but making that a 3d
world as well to bring them together
let's see how you play a painter in this
film and I'm sure you studied and
practice how to paint but even if you
didn't perfect it did it change the way
in which you saw the world to look at a
painter and to try to imagine how a
painter sees the world and that did that
affect performance as well definitely I
mean yes I had some amazing painters and
artists that helped me in preparation
who also did all the wonderful paintings
of
of ideas Lily in our film and I I think
I've had a big fright almost of picking
up a pencil or a piece of charcoal
before in my life but it's also the
wonderful thing when you make a film you
get to try things that you've never had
to do and so it was all about kind of it
was interesting
studying the physicality because of
course I couldn't learn how to paint
those wonderful paintings in there in a
month but it was all about the
confidence in in in an artist knowing it
translating the image in their head onto
the canvas and learning to do those big
strokes and they actually in the end had
me doing some of those big drawings and
they they really it was a big gift that
they gave me that confidence
there was also soldiers feeling amazing
in um in there the difference between
Gerda's work and Lily's work when she
was living in ional living as Einar that
Eve reflected so beautifully in that in
that set which was their different
corners of where they painted and Gerda
had this freedom and this sort of this
eclectic space whereas whereas if you
look at in ours work it in fact lana
wachowski always wrote about it
described diners workers being almost
like coffins they were these sort of
small it was these small little
intricate spaces and that was something
that that was was sort of reflected in
the set as well